[MUSIC]
My first time on Mars was unforgettable.
After touring every corner of the Earth,
living in post-apocalyptic Boston and
studying at a dozen universities,
I thought I had seen it all.
But well on the ground on the red planet,
driving my rover through the whipping
dust, that giddy feeling of
wonder swept over me once again.
Of course,
I wasn't actually in any of these places,
but both my brain and
my body believed that I was.
And at the end of the day,
is there really any difference?
I'm talking, of course,
about virtual reality.
Virtual reality has been called many
things, from a passing fad, like 3D
television, to the next big computing
platform on the level of mobile phones.
By now, many of us have already had
the chance to try out VR once or twice.
And have already started to make
assumptions about the impact that it may,
or may not have.
But regardless of your stance, if I ask
you to picture who's actually using
VR today, most of us will come
up with an image like this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's me,
someone isolated in their living room,
waving their arms furiously
in the air in between sips of Soylent and
handfuls of Doritos.
There's a ton of stigma about VR.
People think it's for gamers or
claim that it's overhyped or
fear that it's going to have
unintended consequences on humanity.
And for the record,
I think these are all legitimate concerns.
But looking beyond them, there is so
much more to virtual reality and
the promise that it holds.
I believe in the future where VR will
be used around the world to improve
people's lives and
bring us closer together.
But we are long way away
from that right now,
which leads us to the biggest
open question facing it today.
What is it really for?
Or perhaps more importantly,
what can it be for?
My own obsession with VR lies
at the heart of this question.
In my quest to answer it, I've tried
to enter VR every single day for
the past few years, even if just for
a few minutes at a time.
In that time, I've seen some things.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I've met people and
made real connections.
I've used it as a tool to improve
learning and education, and
I've even built new worlds and
shared those experience with other people.
But regardless of the specific
application, there is one fundamental
concept that makes VR so promising to me,
and all of it's enthusiasts.
It's its ability to create presence.
Presence is achieved when your brain
truly believes that you no longer just
standing in your bedroom or your living
room but somewhere out entirely.
What VR is and will be for
is anything that requires presence.
And especially when presence is either
expensive or even impossible to achieve.
Consider this, we spend a tremendous
amount of time transporting our physical
brains to places that they're not.
Think of multi-hour commutes or
flying around the world just
to go to a meeting or two.
Why do we do this?
It's because being face
to face with someone,
feeling present in the same room matters.
Video conferencing was heralded as
the technology that was going to end
the office as we know it.
But it never delivered on that promise
because it couldn't achieve presence.
But what if we could create VR experiences
that made you truly feel like you were in
that meeting, with those people?
How would our concept of the commute,
or work in general, change?
While presence is foundational,
what is even more exciting is
what we can build on top of it.
The research shows that
when we're present in VR,
it actually makes us feel like
things are happening to us,
as opposed to us just watching
them happen to someone else.
And when we can truly believe that we
are somewhere, or even someone else, we've
just entered the most powerful vehicle for
empathy that we've ever created.
Now, let's pause and reflect for a moment.
Why did you all come here
today to watch Loki Notes,
instead of just catching
it on YouTube later?
It certainly can't be because of comfort.
I'm sure you couch is much nicer that
these chairs and definitely standing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> On almost all metrics,
the at-home experience is better
than life, except for one,
we come to live events like these
because we want to feel something.
To absorb the energy of the speaker,
and the people around us.
To laugh, and to cry,
and to share those feelings with
the people sitting next to us.
In these live experiences,
it's our presence that powers empathy.
But, we can't always come to live events,
just like we can't always fly
around the world to understand
how people live their lives.
So to achieve presence, we usually rely
on reading stories or watching videos.
But it's one thing to read
a story about Italy or
to see a picture of Rome or
to even watch a movie like Gladiator.
But it's an entirely different thing
to step into Julius Caesar's shoes and
see the world as he did.
The research supports the fact that
when we have experiences even if they're
just simulated ones, it makes us much
better connect with and understand
that content up to four times more than if
were just to read about it or watch it.
So while TV it gives us a window
to peer into another world,
VR lets us step into that world and
throughly immerse ourselves in it.
It's an entirely new medium for
empathetic storytelling.
But what stories can we tell?
Consider Clouds over Sidra,
a VR experience built in partnership
with the United Nations and
presented at the World Economic Forum.
The mission was to take global leaders and
help them better understand
what life is like for a young girl
living in a Syrian refugee camp, and
inspire them to start making a difference.
Or consider melting ice, a VR documentary
featuring Al Gore that transports
people to the remote parts of the world
that are most affected by climate change.
To give them a vivid understanding of
the real impact that it's already having.
VR is also being used to
combat domestic violence.
In a recent study, researchers have taken
men who've committed these acts and
put them in the VR,
except in the body of a woman.
The men are then subjected to
stimulated domestic violence.
And it’s been proven that it actually
makes them more empathetic to the others
around them and
will hopefully prevent future incidents.
These are just a few of
the examples that are possible now.
And everyday, we are learning more
about how we can use VR as
a tool to reimagine empathy.
Well, I'm clearly just a little
bit obsessed about VR.
I don't think that it's me or
even anyone in this room who
stands the most to gain from it.
VR is going to unlock experiences for
the vast majority of people in this world
who don't have access to them right now.
Consider the moment when anyone with
a headset can feel they're sitting in
a classroom at a top university,
listening to inspiring educators and
having real social interactions
with the people next to them.
That's the moment when we've made
world-class education available to anyone.
The release of cheap but high quality
VR headsets in the coming years will
make it possible for everyone,
not just to feel greater empathy, but
to have experiences that were
previously impossible for them to have.
So regardless of the opinion about VR,
you walked in with here today, I
encourage you to broaden your perspective
on what it can and will be for.
Much like how black and
white television or the first mobile phone
only hinted at what was to come,
VR is still very much in its infancy.
It will take time, but
it's a future worth building towards.
And in that future,
everyone will have the ability to
feel present anywhere
with anyone at any time.
And the human race will be much
more connected because of it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]